الى تونس حيث قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني
احمد نجيب الشعبي انه لن يستجيب لاي
استدعاء قضائي ولي يكون طرفا فيما سماها
مسرحيه قضائيه واضاف شاب قامت به السلطه
ضده لعبه سياسيه لن تنطلي على احد مشددا
على ان القضاه الذين سيحققون في قضيته لن
يفلت من العقاب حسب قوله
في تونس اصبح مكانه سجن وان الشعب يقاد
بالعشرات امام القضاء
اذكروا ان رئيسه الحزب الدستوريه عبير
موسي تقدمت بشكوى ضد الشابي وقياديين في
جبهه الخلاص اتهمتهم فيها بالعمل على مع
شخصيات على صله بي جرائم ارهابيه وفق
للدعوه
لن استجيب الى اي استدعاء من من سيتعهد
هذه القضيه لانه لا اساس له من الواقع ولا
في القانون
واني الاستجابه تعني انني جزء من هذه
التمثيليه السيئه الاخراج واذا مجربت
بالقوه
وفقا للقانون
التحقيق يجلب بالقوه فانني لنفس بنت
الشفاء لن اتكلم عن هويتي من انا ولن اجيب
على اي سؤال حتى صدور الحكم النهائي واحمل
منذ الان
القضاه الذين سيتورتون في مثل هذه العمليه
انهم لن يفلوا من العقاب
من تونس تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره ميسال
فطناسي المزيد حول ما ورد في هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي اذا لاحمد نجيب الشابي وايضا هل
كانت تصريحات الرئيس قيس سعيد الاخيره
مرتبطه وفي سياق هذه تهامه التي وجهت الى
الشابي
نعم مياده هو كل من يتابع هذه القضيه
اصبح اليوم يربط بين تصريحات الرئيس
الاخيره والتي قالها في اوقات سابقه حتى
وبين ما همم يعني ما بلغته الامور اليوم
من احاله رئيس جبهه الخلاصه الوطني احمد
نجيب الشاب والقيادي بي الجبهه ايضا الحاج
على التحقيق رغم ان هذا هذه حاله تاتي على
خلفيه الشيكايه الجزائيه التي تقدمت بها
رئيسه حزب الدستوري الحر عبير موسى ضد
الشابي ورضا بالحاج والدقيقه الاخرين من
جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه المعارضه اليوم
السابع اعتبر بان السلطه ورغم انها لا
تتفق سياسيا مع عبير موسي الا انها وظفت
هذه الشكايه التي تقدمت بها عبير موسى
والتي اخذت همم منحها القضائي بشكل سريع
جدا خلال اسبوع واحد فقط بعد تقديم
الشكايه تم اعلان احمد نجيب الشابي ورضا
بالحاج احالتهم على
التحقيق اذا احمد نجيب الشابي يعتبر ان
السلطه وظفت هذه الشكايه للانتقام وايه
ارسلت المعارضين السياسيين لها احمد نجيب
الشاب يعتبر بانه من خلال هذه الاحاله على
التحقيق ومن خلال ايضا احاله المحامي
العياشي الهمامي وهو منسق هيئه الدفاع عن
القضاه المعزولين ومن خلال احالته وايضا
على التحقيق ومن خلال كل ما سبق من احالات
للسياسيين ولا الصحافيين ولمدونين
نشطاء وغيرهم كل هذا يؤشر بان همم
الاستهداف المعارضين واستهداف كل من يعارض
ومن ينطق بكلمه تعارض السلطه السياسيه
الحاليه فان السلطه جوابها همم تجاه هؤلاء
هو احالاتهم على القضاء واستهدافهم قضائيا
واعتبر بان هذا الامر اصبح سياسه بالنسبه
لسلطه اذا احمد نجيب الشابي اوضح اليوم
وتحدث بشكل واضح بانه لن يستجيب لهذه
الدعوه اي انه لن يتوجه الى قاضي التحقيق
وهمم عند استدعائه وعند تحديد موعد لي
التحقيق معه وان اخذ بالقوه فانه لن ينطق
باي كلمه في التحقيق واعتبر بان الاستجابه
لهذه القضيه وبالتعامل معها بالاستجابه
لها هو التزكيه لها وانه يرفض القيام بذلك
ايضا احمد نجيب الشاب يتحدث عن القضاء
ودوره في هذا في هذه القضيه واعتبر بان
القضاء الذي يسارع على اتخاذ اجراءات
استثنائيه في مثل هذه القضايا هو قضاء
تابع للسلطه وليس قضاءا مستقلا
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من تونس مراسله الجزيره
ميساء فاطمه